can you guys hear me okay perfect so
let's get started uh welcome to lecture
number four of the AI in the science and
engineering course Ben has been teaching
you till now and I teach today and then
he comes back and then I come back in
two weeks time and that's how and after
that I teach for quite a quite a while
okay so what have you learned so far so
essentially in the last couple of
lectures or the lecture before that what
Ben has done as I've seen the slides
myself in the recording is that has
given you a very suent introduction to
deep learning so let me use some
highlighting color
so you can see this when I highlight
okay perfect so what is deep learning he
has introduced deep neural networks and
somehow the basis of deep learning today
are several things the first is of
course data so you have large data large
data this is very very important you'll
see that in the sort of uh the context
of the course this might not be as large
as you'd like but we'll get to that and
then you have neural networks and you
have good uh gr and decent
algorithms and what is often a key
towards um making machine learning work
is the ability to generalize okay and
you'll see repeatedly this word come in
during at least my lectures so now after
having this crash course on machine
learning what we're going to do for for
several lectures is to apply it in some
scientific context and this scientific
context would be in the beginning
physics based and towards the end of the
lecture lectures towards the end of the
course chemistry and biology but uh in
the realm of physics what we are going
to focus on is uh those physical models
that are governed by PD partial
differential equations so let me start
with that and today my objective is to
give you a very brief introduction to
pdes and also to say what are the
challenges
why you need to do something which is
different from what we need to do how
does machine learning come in and what's
the scope what's the what's the goal
here so let me let me get started with
that so what are PS right many of you
might have seen them before particularly
those were students of physics
engineering chemistry and so on because
uh but essentially to sort of introduce
the concept to introduce the Paradigm
let me tell you or give you a quote from
her Simon hbert Simon was a Nobel
laurate he won the Nobel prize in
economics in 1978 and he did many
interesting things about um Behavior
complex systems he also wrote a paper
called what is complexity and from this
paper I have taken out this quote okay
and let me quote him so given a
blueprint to find the corresponding
recipe so this is his sort of context
much of the activity in science is an
application of this Paradigm given the
description of some some natural
phenomena so this is the keyword here so
given the description of some natural
phenomena the phenomena could be how the
weather evolves or something as simple
as when I'm speaking how does the sound
waves that I'm producing reach you right
how do these waves or how does the sound
that I'm making propagate this could be
as simple as that then what Herbert
Simon Says and this is the recipe for
science is that you find the
differential equations so now of course
it doesn't seem to work so find the
differential equations that of the
process right that is going to produce a
phenomena or what is he saying he's
saying that if you have any physical
phenomenon of Interest could be the
weather it could be the propagation of
sound waves it could be what happens
when I heat up one part of the room when
someone starts a fire unintentionally in
all these problems there is a process
there are some phenomena and what we
need to do in order to describe this
phenomena scientifically is to write
down the differential equations that
govern them right so this is sort of the
key key point in other words uh my
paraphrasing of it which is written here
is that if you have a scientific problem
give me a second if you have a
scientific problem essentially you find
a differential equation but in general
you find a partial differential equation
that is going to describe right so this
is somehow the Paradigm that we are
going to operate and you might have seen
it in your courses you might have seen
it in your projects that this is sort of
ubiquitous so you take any kind of
phenomena and the first thing that we do
in order to write down a mathematic iCal
model is that we write down a
differential equation so what are these
partial differential equations that we
are going to study we're going to see
intimately in the last uh sever in the
next several lectures so essentially
this is let me let me draw a cartoon a
sketch so what you do is uh let's say
that you are having a open set domain D
here and uh this is the let's say this
room here the room that we are sitting
in and standing in so this is going to
be your domain D so this is the the
thing here D is your dimension of your
space for us it's threedimensional but
it could be one dimension it could be
two dimensions in some problems it could
be thousands of Dimensions you'll also
see that during the progression of this
course so you have open Set uh the room
as I can see here and then you have to
take some quantity of Interest so let me
quickly write down so you have a
quantity of
interest and this is what we denote as U
okay so this quantity of Interest could
be anything let's take a very simple one
let's say it's the
temperature so of course the temperature
is at any point in space and at any time
step any point in time right so the
temperature for instance in this room is
going to change uh it's high during the
day it's relatively low during the night
and so on and so forth and also it
changes in this room it doesn't really
change but if you look at the city of
Zurich for sure it changes as we as we
move along as we it's different at the
lake than it's on the top of uber for
instance right so you have a dynamic
phenomena you have a quantity of
interest and you have physical laws and
this is important to State here so you
have some physical laws so and these
physical laws for instance for the
spread of temperature it is called Fier
law it could be Newton's law of gravity
it could be whatever and these physical
laws are quot ified in terms of a
mathematical object which looks like
this so it's a complicated nonlinear
relationship as you can see this is the
nonlinearity here it's a complicated
nonlinear relationship which takes the
quantity and relates it for instance to
the gradient so what is the gradient
just for notation gradient of U is U X1
the vector ux1 ux2
ux3 and similarly you have the time
derivative you have the second
derivative which is just the Matrix
thean Matrix which puts all these things
together so essentially what the
physical law says is that you have a
relationship a very complicated
nonlinear relationship I emphasize
between the quantity of interest and its
derivatives because these derivatives
for instance tell you how things change
right how things change in time is given
by the temporal derivative how things
change in space is given by the spatial
derivatives the spatial second
derivatives and so on and you put them
in a bin and this complicated non lar
relation gives you a PD so I'm sure that
all of you have seen these kind of PDs
before if in some form or the other and
this is sort of a very generic form of
it of course in practice we deal with
much s concrete examples of this and
this is what I'm going to give you in
the next two or 3 minutes so these are
different examples of PDs and just to
illustrate the sort of differ scales at
which we can operate so you can start
right from the scale of atoms or even
Elementary particles that that
constitute atoms so this here is sort of
a molecule as you can see and the PD
that comes in here uh let me write it
down is shorting this
equation shorting this
equation again this is the fundamental
equation of chemistry and atomic physics
or molecular physics and the equation is
something like uh let me write it down
laian of s plus some potential V okay so
this is s is what is called the wave
function oh
sorry how many of you have in this class
have seen the rting this equation
before so more than half you haven't
seen the shingus equation
okay I'm bit surprised if you go to
Wikipedia you can easily read very
quickly what it is so this is what is
called a wave function it tells us what
is the probability let's say that we
have a single electron which is moving
around uh the nucleus it tells you the
probability of finding that electron at
a certain position and at certain
momentum for instance this is a typical
example this laian this is the complex
imaginary complex number the the unit
imaginary number I and laian is the
trace of the hian okay so this is the
trace of the Hessian just in case gradi
secondary you and this is some sort of a
potential so this tells you the kinetic
energy this term here and this tells you
the potential energy so all of us in
some sense are walking representations
of the shorting equation because at the
end of the day we are made up of atoms
and electrons and so on and so forth and
if you put all of them together we'll
have a very very very high dimensional
strting equation so the fundamental
equation of chemistry and atomic physics
is the stringers
equation uh which is a partial
differential equation right and in order
to do these kind of things like nano
technology to design some n nanom
material for instance you need to solve
the shingus equation in some form or the
other otherwise you can't design it
here's another example this is of course
was in the news in the last 3 four years
which is uh detection of gravitational
waves as you can see these are two black
holes which are coming towards each
other and in the Collision they generate
a lot of gravitational waves and these
were the waves that were detected by by
the by the gravitational Observatory
back in the US right so this is uh and
what are the equations that govern these
kind
of phenomena who can tell me so if you
have the Coalition of black holes and
generation of gravitational waves
yes of what kind
of
Einstein okay so these are the Einstein
field equations this I don't even dare
to write down because I won't be able to
finish but let me just write the name
here so okay what happened here so
thanks so these are the Einstein
equations and Einstein of course is the
most famous alumnus of eth so and it's
just fitting that his equations these
are a very complicated set of partial
differential
equations so you can write them in
different forms different guyses but uh
these These are partial differential
equations and so you started at the
scale of an electron which is a highy
subatomic particle and this is really at
the scale like a universal scale right
so you have like 30 40 50 orders of
magnitude difference in the scales that
we are looking for but all these
phenomena needless to say are modeled by
partial differential equations and this
is of course an example of the average
temperature so Global Climate very much
in the news and the global as you'll see
later on in the course we have some
details about it global climate is also
modeled by systems of
pdes and if you look at it so global
climate is a very complex interplay
between different physical processes so
you have fluid motion right so this is
in the atmosphere and the ocean you have
fluid motion and the equations that
govern fluid flow are what are called
the Navia Stokes equations so you have
Navia
Stokes again we will see that in quite
some detail in later lectures so that is
the fundamental sort of block here fluid
flow equations of course it is supp
mented or augmented by things like
radiation so again another thing that we
are going to see radiative transfer
equations uh these are also pdes
radiative
transfer and there are other other pdes
that come in in the global climate
systems so there are bunch of PDs couple
PDS which sort of govern the evolution
of the of of our climate and needless to
say so this is again at a large scale at
the scale of the Earth but even at the
scale of a human being or biological
organism for instance this is this is a
fly Wing So the fly is the fruit fly
that we the common fruit fly of which is
used in biology labs and the equations
that govern it are what are called
reaction diffusion equations again some
things that we are going
to we are going to see reaction
diffusion
equations and the reason why I put this
particular picture here of how a
flywing evolves really when it's uh you
know when it's in an embrionic stage is
because I myself wrote down these
equations so that's why it's my
equations they're not not comparable to
Einstein's equations but I wrote them so
it's uh something I'm proud of uh anyway
so this are as you can see again
different kinds of phenomena you started
with materials went all the way to the
universal scales then you went down to
the Earth and then at the level of an
organism biology chemistry physics
climate science all these things all
these different scientific domains but
the common language in which we express
them are given by these mathematical
objects right so this is the sort of the
beauty of the thing that even very very
different phenomena and I personally
have studied almost all of them but from
this vantage point because it allows you
to express very very different things
very very different physical systems and
express them in one particular
mathematical language which is the
language of Aral differential equations
that's why they are very very important
and the con Institute the bulk of at
least this course where we are going to
use machine learning uh machine learning
to sort of uh solve this partial
differential equations okay and as I
said you'll see many many examples
during concrete examples during this
course how many of you can uh know the
Navia Stokes equations how many of you
have seen the Navia Stokes equations
just to have a ballp
part okay others will find out right so
that's good
okay so now once you have these
equations whether it's a string equation
NAIA Stokes equations Einstein's
equations even Einstein himself he was
only able to solve his own equations in
a very very special case he's barely
able to solve it he wrote down the
equations um in
1915 and even today you you don't have a
formula to solve these equations right
you know that very well that even simple
algebraic equations cannot be solved let
alone this kind of differential
equations the point is is that U we
cannot use pen and paper to solve these
equations because uh there is no way we
can we can find formulas right except in
very very special cases none of these
equations that I wrote down you can find
formulas except in special cases so what
do we do in that case so in absence of
formulas how do we solve these equations
so what we do is uh essentially can be
summed up by one word which is
approximation so we don't solve these
equations exactly because we can't uh
simply unable to but we can approximate
them so instead of saying that the
temperature in this room is exactly that
can be more or less exactly solved if
you know the boundary conditions and so
on but nevertheless we do an
approximation and this is what is done
by what are called traditional numerical
methods means um so here are the let me
highlight this so traditional numerical
methods so you have a PD and people have
been writing down does anyone know who
wrote down the first partial
differential equ so who wrote down the
first differential equation let's do a
pop quiz here who who do you think wrote
down the first differential
equation someone else
yes a differential equation it could be
an ordinary differential equation also
not a partial differential equation yes
Newton actually Newton did
so Newton saw the first uh he wrote down
because he wrote down his Laws of Motion
through that's why he more or less had
to invent calculus right because he
could he could discover or he could
write down the equations but the first
partial differential equation as you
said was actually written down by Oiler
who is probably the most famous Swiss
scientist and he wrote down what is
called Oilers equations and the Oilers
equations let me just write down so
these were Oilers equations so this C
the flow of a what is called an ideal
fluid what Navi and Stokes realized is
that no fluid is ideal so you have to
make some approximation and that's how
they came up with the Navia Stokes
equations and this equation was written
down more or less in the form that we
still use it today in
1757 so that is the year in which the in
which Oiler wrote down is oiless
equations and let me tell you even today
uh there are thousands or tens of
thousands of people who study the Oilers
equation because we still don't
understand everything about them so it's
it's sort of remarkable but from 1757 to
let's say I don't don't know me
1928 I think was the year till then from
almost um almost 200 years 175 years how
people solved equations was by writing
formulas you see they tried to find out
some special situation how you can solve
it for instance Oiler himself and many
others they did
this and they also used what are called
ASM totic expansions they would expand
things in tailor expansions and then
they will try to match coefficients and
so on but in 1928 around 19 late 1920s
there was a revolution because there was
a first person his name is Richardson he
was a physicist in
Cambridge so what Richardson came up
with is an idea to use computers at that
time analog computers to solve by using
what are called numerical methods so
these are ways in which you take a
partial differential equation and you
discretize it I'm just telling you the
words discretize it and uh this started
the field of modern numerical approxim
of differential equations both ordinary
and partial differential equations and
the reason why Richardson even started
this process is because he wanted to
predict the weather and it is and today
the weather is predicted by solving
these equations so in a way his program
succeeded Beyond uh you know the weather
is very very accurately predicted so
that's so what what he realized and what
many other people contributed for noyman
in particular is another name that
stands out another alumnus of eth
who contributed significantly and this
is during the Manhattan Project so from
1940 to
1945 uh during the second world war he
realized that you can't build a nuclear
bomb without simulating it without
without finding out how how it behaves
and for that he and his group derived a
lot of interesting numerical methods so
of course to do this course you don't
need to know what numerical methods are
but you need to know that this is going
to be the primary form in which we are
going to derive data you know the our
data is mostly going to come from
numerical methods and there are a wide
variety of them as you can see this is
almost 100 year old subject so there is
lot of lot of activity lot of research
lot of ideas lot of code and so on and
maybe I'll try to give you a very very
brief glimpse of what it is the most
popular methods are what are called
finite difference methods finite volume
methods finite element methods
collocation spectral methods let's got
spectral methods and so on and so forth
and just again as a pop quiz here just
to get an idea of what I'm dealing with
in this class how many of you have um
seen a finite difference method for
instance so yeah many people but not
everyone okay but doesn't matter so I
presume that the infinite elements how
many have seen is the same even less
finite elements okay fair enough so then
we have to we have to do something but
these are sort of the current Paradigm
for numerical methods and for those who
haven't seen this let me just
recapitulate the simplest numerical
method that you can imagine so I take a
pde so this is the heat equation so here
is the heat equation I take it in one
space Dimension so now I realize I don't
know how big this is yeah so I realize
that uh at least to me I don't see see
my see my grid so I'll just expand it a
little bit here
yeah so what is the idea so this is the
heat equation uh U so U is the
temperature so you have the temperature
for instance in this room but of course
the room is not one dimensional so I
kept things simple and the domain that
you're looking at is here 0 to 1 right
in space so the space is from 0 to 1 and
time is from 0 to capital T okay so this
is your your domain and uh this equation
is not enough you need to give what are
called initial conditions so what is the
temperature now and then we can predict
the temperature in the future so these
are the initial conditions that are
given here and we also need some
boundary conditions so just for
Simplicity so boundary conditions for
instance would what would be the
temperature on all the walls here right
so for Simplicity I just put zero so
along these uh here and here it will all
be zero okay just imagine that you have
ice blocks and then you heat up
something okay so this is the heat
equation as you can see and uh this
particular equation we can actually
solve it by hand there are solution
formulas which are based on Green's
function to solve these equations but we
can also easily simulate it approximate
it on a computer and the way we do it is
very simple so first we have the domain
which is uh A Spacetime domain this box
as you can see so let me write it down
so it's um 01 so the okay DT this is the
domain let's say 01 * 0
t and this domain as you can see instead
of having it's it's a sort of a
continuous object it's a instead of a
Continuum object instead of that I have
discretized it so I broken it down into
these tiny points and at each of these
points so the way I have done it is that
I have um I have a Delta X so this is
what is called a mesh
size and similarly I have a in time I
have a delta T as as you can see so
delta T this is a Time
step and then I have broken down
everything this entire domain just into
a collection of points so this domain
here becomes a collection of points XJ
TN XJ as you can see is J * Delta X and
TN is n * delta T so instead of having a
continuous domain I just have a lattice
or a mesh or cloud cloud of points in
this particular case it's going to be a
mesh so that's the first thing because
we cannot put continuous quantities on
the computer so we have to put some
discrete quantities digital quantities
so we we did this right this is this is
an elementary step but that's not enough
because we also have the differential
equation right so this was just taking
so what we're going to do is we're going
to approximate the solution U at X jtn
at these points by some discrete object
which we are going to call as VJ okay as
you can see maybe in the picture also it
is here the vng and and it's not enough
because we also have this derivatives so
you have UT the time derivative you have
XX uxx the second derivative in space so
what we are going to do is we're going
to approximate these derivatives by
finite differences so here is a finite
difference right this is a finite
difference and this is the simplest
possible finite difference so if you
take a derivative this is what we
learned in calculus we take a derivative
and we replace it with a for difference
and we take the second derivative and we
replace it with the central difference
okay so it's as simple as that so in
principle any differential operator
which is derivatives locally right so
what you can do is that you can do
tailor expansions and you can
approximate it in terms of these kind of
finite differences uh of course we are
on a regular or uniform grid so it is
very simple uh you can do that and then
when you just take these two together
you know that this so we say that this
finite difference equals to this finite
difference so when you do that you end
up with the numerical method so the
numerical method tells you so this is a
Lambda some some parameter that I have
defined here which is the ratio of the
time step to the square of the M size
but in general what does it tell me so
if you look at this picture what it
tells me is that I can March in time so
given the solution here I can predict
the solution at the next time step
because all that I need are the values
here the values here and the values here
similarly if I want to go here I need
the values here the values here and the
values here which is supplied to me by
the boundary right so it's a Time
marching process I start initially go to
the first time step I have all the
values the first time step go to the
next time step go to the next time step
and so on and this is very easy to code
up on Modern computers and as a
consequence you can also see and show
that this is indeed a solution or an
approximation to the solution of the
heat equation so this is a finite
different scheme and finite different
schemes are very easy when you have like
cartisian domains and so on when you
have complicated domains like for
instance uh this this is a aircraft so
this is just the nose section of an
aircraft and you want to simulate flow
around it so here for instance then you
need uh more complicated uh measures you
cannot use cartisian grids anymore and
you need more complicated methods like
finite volume methods and finite element
methods and so on but these are these
are details and this is not the
objective of this course
right so you have a finite difference or
a finite element finite volume spectal
methods and this will give you an
approximation of the exact solution and
this works very very well means as I
said this is something which is 100
years
old and even in my lab we have all kinds
of examples of exotic phenomena that are
solved using numerical methods so as you
can see here let me give you a quick
quick to so this is the core collapse of
a supernova supernova is a massive star
it's dying and how is the Dynamics and
you can see that there's some very
complex physics in 3D which has been
simulated with this nuclear with this
kind of numerical methods this one was
with a
finite uh finite volume method I think
yeah finite volume method this one is
more with the finite difference method
uh this is clouds so you you start with
dynamics of clouds start cumulus clouds
again done with a finite difference
method
here and uh this is the propagation so
this a landslide and the landslide hits
the lake or in this case a particular
Bay excites a tsunami again can be
modeled by some shallow water equations
and then you solve them with some finite
volume method and this is the flow past
an aircraft or rocket and this is done
with a finite element so all this is
done in my lab for instance and you know
that there are all kinds of success ful
examples of these methods so they work
they they're very good and they work but
what we say or what we argue today and
what we going to sort of try and address
during the course of these lectures is
even though these methods work very well
they are time tested for 100 years now
there are some issues with them and this
is why I wanted to briefly describe what
these issues are as quickly as I can so
what's the caveat right why do we care
anymore the caveat is that you'll see in
a second that these method so if you
look at the method for the heat equation
so the one that I just showed
you so if you remember that I had a mesh
size and a Time step right so it turns
out that for different stability reasons
your time step has to scale in a certain
manner it is to scale as a square of the
mes size because after all this was the
quantity that came in right delta T over
Delta X
squ and the error the amount of error
that we make because we had critizing
that also scales in terms of the square
of the meas size you can you can show
that for this particular example for the
finite difference method so this is
going to be the error but what is a
compute what is the computational cost
to get certain amount of error so that
depends on the number of mesh points so
in 1D it is very simple it is 1 / Delta
X right but in 2D you just have 1 /
Delta X in each Direction so it is 1 /
Delta x s in 3D it's 1/ Delta X cubed
and so on so the points they scale in
terms of this a negative sign me for
some reason I forgot to put a negative
sign so scale exponentially in the
dimension in some sense right the time
step the number of time steps is
essentially one over 1 / delta T sorry
so it is Delta x^ s so now the compute
is the computational cost of this is the
total number of proportional because per
m point per time step you do a certain
amount of arithmetic operations so it is
proportional to this um to the product
of these guys so this is the scaling
it's a very simple scaling so if you
look at the computational complexity
this is I just take this equation here
this equation here and I substitute and
I get a relationship which is like this
okay and the scaling means the scale
factor could be 10 it could be 100 it
could be whatever but it's a finite
scale factor and now if you start
putting in let's say in three Di
mentions it is 3 5 over2 right 5 over
two and if you want an error of 1 1%
that is 1 over 100 right and uh so this
is 100 to the^ 5/ 2 square root of
100,000 but that's not enough because
you also have a scale factor which is
like 100 so you can see that the
computational cost it's going it's going
to be large okay so even if we have good
methods the the point is that the
compute is always going to grow
exponentially with Dimension so in
particular this is what this formula
shows us right in particular in 3D you
will have difficulties with the
numerical methods I'll give you an
example but is this point clear that
just from very very basic Elementary
scaling we know that in order to get a
certain amount of error the compute has
to scale exponentially somehow and
because of that the computational volume
is going to be very very large okay and
this leads to issues right in particular
there are some other issues also so the
the most important issue is
computational cost that's why I want to
write it here but there are other issues
for instance to generate a grid is not
easy um you have multiscale multi
physics problems High dimensional
problems all these cases because
remember that the compute scales
exponentially Dimension so if you want
to solve a 100 dimensional problem or a
10 dimensional problem already this is
uh the compute sces as a factor of six
which is power of six
which is just insanely large right 100
to the^ 6 is a very very high number so
it's a lot of compute and because of
that there are many many problems which
are interesting for instance boltzman
equation or shingus equation shingus
equation the number of Dimensions
depends on the number of particles that
you're Elementary particles that you're
looking at so even for um very very
simple atoms you are out you know like
carbon for instance you have many
electrons and many states and this
becomes easily a 100 dimensional
thousand dimensional problem so you
cannot solve them or if you solve them
with a numerical method this is going to
be very very expensive so that is one
one computational challenge another
computational challenge is what are
called um many query problems so what
are these many query problems uh these
are multiple calls to a PD
solver multiple calls through a PD
solver sometimes they can be
parallelized but often they are
sequential and then it becomes each call
is very expensive then if you have to do
it 100 times it just grows very very
expensive let me give you an example so
this is um an air foil it's um a section
of the wing so when you design the wing
of an aircraft uh the first step is to
First design each cross-section right so
the cross-section is an air foil it has
this typical tear drop shape for
aerodynamic um sort of reasons right so
to reduce the drag to the lift and so on
and the way this design is done whether
it's by boing or Airbus or any aircraft
design company is very simple so what
you do is that you take a starting point
so this is uh the black here is a
starting point of the of the wing of the
air foil and then you solve the
equations these are either depending on
the regime either the oiler or the Navia
Stokes equations the same equations
which have been around for more than 200
years and then you see if the then you
do a gradient descent and see how to
reduce the lift or not to reduce the
lift but to keep the lift constant and
keep on reducing the drag so you you you
compute a gradient and then you move
step by step in order to reduce the lift
in the drag but the point is this might
take you easily 100 or thousand
iterations but for each iteration you
have to do this kind of a forward solve
you have to solve the PD numerically
which is done here by using in this
particular case a finite volume method
but here it's not like you're solving
the PD once you're solving it a thousand
times and you cannot do it parallell
right because you need a previous value
in order to go to the next value and
then to the next value and so on so
that's why this is a computationally
very expensive problem for instance
boing they spend I know this from their
Chief technology officer that they spend
approximately $2 billion a year 2
billion on their compute budget which is
a lot of it goes towards of course they
have not spent enough otherwise their
windows will not crash out and and so on
they probably need to spend 5 billion
but you can imagine that this this is
expensive and you'll see why in a second
this is expensive because you have to do
multiple multiple calls you have to do
multiple multiple trials because this is
what design is all about right but the
point is multiple calls here so this is
another example this is what is called
an inverse problem uh let me look at the
time I have to be
quick so this is to detect the the
geology of the earth underneath NE so
how is this done suppose you want to
find out what are what are the
geophysical properties of the soil in
jich for instance or the rock formation
in jich so what people do is that they
they have a they have a set of
sensors which are located here they have
a truck uh on land it's typically a
truck on on water it's a ship and this
has a this has a wave generator so it is
generating W waves which it is sending
into the sub soft surface so the wave
equation which is utt minus c² of X of U
this is what is being solved this is a
wave
equation and then what what happens is
that these waves get reflected right so
these waves get reflected they're
captured by sensors and they're captured
in time right they're observed in time
so what you get is uh sort of a
measurement field which looks like this
very noisy um you know this kind of time
snap shots these are for different
sensors uh you get you get a measurement
field like that and what you have to
solve is an inverse problem because here
you know the solution in some sense but
you don't know the coefficient this this
guy here because this tells us the
geological properties of the the soil so
this is the c² of X and then you have to
invert then it is going to look
something like this okay so here it's an
inverse problem again it is solved in
iterative manner so you start with a
guess then you solve the forward problem
see if things match and then move in the
direction of the gradient so again it
takes um 100 to a th iterations in order
to get anything acceptable and these 100
to th000 iterations or 10,000 iterations
are PS to the PD solver which make this
very difficult we will we will look at
this problem later in the course in some
detail okay so this was another example
uncertainty quantification so if you
have a turbulent fluid flow it doesn't
make any sense to to essentially do
point wise measurements or because you
can see that this flow becomes very very
turbulent so what you need to do is to
compute statistics mean variance and so
on which are much more stable but
statistics we know is over 100 samples
thousand samples 10,000 samples and this
makes it very very expensive right and
how expensive I'll just give you an idea
so this is why I said what is the
computational cost for doing these
things right so I know the cost here
because I have to pay it in some form or
the other so here is an example so this
is a fluid flow so this is an obious
Stokes
equation this is an academic test case
but you get an idea and this is the
initial condition and this is the final
solution and as you can see this is a
very very rich solution right me you can
see that there are all these vertices
and worlds and uh things move around and
so on so this is a very complex Solution
that's why you need to compute things
like the mean which is here the variance
which is here and this requires so this
is a very high resolution simulation and
this requires approximately 1,24
samples not enough but this is what we
could afford and we go to the biggest
supercomputer in Switzerland which is p
Dain we have a highly optimized code
which is developed in my lab and for a
single sample even in uh for this
problem it requires about 100 node hours
right but we need I think it was even
samples no maybe 1,24 samples so this
requires 100,000 node hours but of
course this is not cheap right because
uh this machine has to someone has to
buy the machine they have to power it
there are people who are actually in the
audience who are employed by the by cscs
the super Computing Center here so all
these things are necessary this these
are cost of course we we get some grants
but if you had to pay like a private
person then just for this simulation we
would have to pay half a million sh
pranks okay now you can imagine why the
budget of boing is 2 billion right when
for a single simulation I have to pay
half a million Swiss FRS so this is uh
this is the thing that it's um even if
these methods are there and they work
well the computational cost is just
prohibitively expensive but that's not
the only thing this is the last point I
want to make and it's a very important
point because uh you know the Dynamics
of the atmosphere they follow the nav
stockes equation this is not hard to
argue if you go to a fluid dynamics 10
one course you can easily learn this but
there's a lot of lot of interesting
phenomena where the physics is much more
let's say flaky missing or uncertain for
instance even in a earth System model
like the one that we have the fluid
dynamics the equations are known the
thermodynamics the equations are known
radiation the equations are known but
you also have the role of vegetation for
instance you know forests they
contribute to how how for instance our
climate is going to change if you take
all the forests for instance then of
course the temperature is going to be
very different than we had forests but
now what is the evolution equation for a
tree right this is essentially what it
boils down to similarly land right how
land absorbs the quality of soil how it
absorbs how it reflects this also tells
you something about the Earth system
again we don't have any sort of first
principles physics to tell us how this
is done so for instance in a climate
model quite a bit of it is based on
sound physics quite a bit of it is based
on missing physics right so this is not
just about missing missing parameters
but really missing physics another
example that I really like to show is
because again I'm involved jointly with
some startup here from eth and they try
to model the traffic in JX so you can
see that this is the lake this is the
big bridge at BW and the itth is
somewhere up here so you have uh the
traffic in JC so you can make some
assumptions and you can can write down
some equations to govern because traffic
is also thought of as a flow things flow
so you can write down some Navia Stokes
like equations but there is no the you
know there is no sort of in principle
abinal derivation of these equations so
again I would say that the physics is
going to be missing but what we have is
lots of data right so we have lots of
data but the physics is going to be
missing similarly if you want to this is
an example of flow in our brain uh again
the same same kind of phenomena comes in
that a lot of physics is actually
missing we don't really know how the
biological circuits how they are
contributing to affect this fluid flow
the point is that even though even if
the physics uh is known it can be
expensive to simulate and there are many
many problems where the physics is even
unknown okay so these are the problems
physical systems that we have to deal
with and what we are going to do is as I
said that uh they're either expensive
like in many query problems or high
dimensional problems or with systems
within complete physics yet they have
lots of data so what we're going to do
in the rest of the course is to address
these kind of problems can we reduce the
cost when the methods are feasible can
we make it feasible when things are INF
feasible and can we for instance augment
our physics or fill in the missing
physics with data so this is what is
going to be the content of several
lectures now um quite a few weeks where
we're going to find alternative
strategies and these alternative
strategies will combine physics and data
in order to be able to use deep learning
okay and that will be the content so I
think in the next lecture uh just to
give you a preview so Ben is going to be
back and he's going to teach you
something called physics
in neural networks uh something called
pins NE networks of pins and the idea
would be that uh we would use neural
network to completely replace the
existing numerical solver which is
essentially so if you remember the heat
equation so instead of using this we'll
just solve this problem using neuron
networks but that is what uh Ben is
going to talk about okay so if there are
no further questions I will stop here
and I look forward to seeing you guys in
two weeks okay byebye